it's really compared to I mean you could
have worse look-alikes
it is flattering because obviously he's
a sex symbol women liking because he's a
bit of a bad boy
some people say I've got the same eyes
got the same color eyes as him we didn't
got a scar on my lip and he's got a scan
isn't it
I just think I've probably got the same
jaw line as him and that's probably why
on the side profile I look exactly like
him
[Music]
my name's scott blower I'm 47 and I've
been a gardener for the past 25 years
the first time someone ever said I look
like the guy who was in Milan for for
burning the girl he would be on the bar
she'd watched the film I think it was
called red I know somebody that he was
in I mean I don't really watch much TV
to be fair I really like peaky blinders
and she's good really gonna look like
the guy so the three-piece suit 225 the
overcoat 120 the fob and chain with a
watch and much box
I was 120 yeah 40 pound shoes 90 pound
and if you've got a completely outfit
you can also get a fake gun for around
500 pounds you just feel really smart
when you're dressed in all the gear but
I've been slated in social media but
nothing like in blah blah but I think
that proper die-hard peaky blinders and
I've got six Skinit online
and even when I just do me no more
clothes back up I'll take the kids to
the trauma center and they'll run over
and say hey Killian Killian kids of I
what's going on and I just tell him I
look like but they think it's something
he'd say ever since I was a kid hates up
in the picture taken when I do events
it's just picture after picture after
pitch after pitch ins your mom can't
work you out I don't know why I'm doing
it but I actually don't mind it no I
think he's just just get used to it I
find it bizarre to be agreeable you know
turning up a party and acting like
someone I'm a few selfies with making
people's day a few drinks and a life and
then come on he wants to do that as a
job I love it
think he's quite similar to me
absolutely really like you mind
mannerisms as well what people say he's
kind of mannerism at least his face
stays special to decide on as well my
song be so jealous
I love this
I mean you put me
you actually think for one second if
anything I'd say no no no no I've given
Bob probably about 180 now that will
tend to it I'm running with it see where
it takes me
I still still like doing the gardening
book like a same getting on a bit now so
if I get on the BBC dr. grey as he's
extra you could do some long shots and
put me in there and let him stay in bed
I thought the way it's gonna tell you
together I don't know he looks like me
anyway I'm older than him so we look
like me I was here first so he should be
in to be in English